mein nächster gast ist nicht dominik
porsche bald ich bin hier zu gast bei
wie hat ein kriegsschiff verträgt die
filme aber sensationell unbedingt
abonnieren
dort gibt es nämlich ganz gut
filmkritiken glaube ich für euch doch
diese wird immer vor kinostart ganz
genau und dieses mal geht es dort um
ralf rechts und da gibt es etwas
besonderes ich hatte nämlich die ehre
fünf sekunden in diesem film
synchronisieren für richtig ja hammer
und zwar den streetview und diesen
ausschnitt könnte jetzt erst mal sehen
was für ein tag
und ich will noch ein bisschen kennen
aber nur wenn du bezahlt und bei der
ganzen riesen special auf dem kanal das
richtig man sieht sämtliche szenen
bilder vom regisseur beziehungsweise
interview und man sieht auch wieder film
bezeichnet wird das ziemlich cool
sensationell und auf kriegs um heißt es
jetzt nicht wann kommt franck sondern er
ist anna fischer dieses rätsel lösen
zum zweiten mal ein sehr lustiges
interview mit ihr die die rolle der
winnie op-bereich synchronisiert ja wir
sind hier im disneyland paris hier wird
gefeiert 20 jahre diesen elend und wenn
hier im disneyland weihnachten gefeiert
wird dann in aller perfektion und damit
sind wir auch schon beim thema bei ralf
reichertz
ok herzlich willkommen im disneyland
paris und wir feiern 20 jahre disneyland
und verzauberte weihnachten ist anfang
november und weihnachtsstimmung kommen
sie damit zurecht finde aber irgendwie
weihnachtsbaum und irgendwie das ganze
flair hier bringt ein abstimmung das
muss man sagen wenn weihnachten dann
disneyland weil hier ist alles ins
kleinste detail perfekt
absolut womit wir beim thema wären
reicht's auch bis kleinste detail
perfekt keine überleitung du spielst
eine darf man gar nicht sagen wenn man
wirklich sagt wenn du spielst weil dann
würde man das ende schon verraten
du spielst eine figur in einem
videospiel sie ist rennfahrerinnen die
sag ich nicht keine fahrerin also ist er
also warum ein bisschen komplizierter
wenn ein op ist es mal sie möchte gerne
rennverein werden aber immer eine
bildstörung das heißt die flackert immer
und deswegen ist eine außenseiterin und
gehört nicht wirklich dazu gehört nicht
zur gruppe und die haben angst das spiel
irgendwie dass die leute draußen denken
können also dieses spiel spielen das
spiel sei kaputt und deswegen wird
ziemlich angenommen und auf jeden fall
wert sie dann durch im kreis hilfe
kriegt sie ein rennauto und kämpfen und
wird dann aber irgendwie das wirkt als
wäre sie auch leib geschrieben und zwar
nicht nur als wärst hier auf den leib
geschrieben sondern sie sieht aus wie du
und deine stimme passt 1500 prozentig
auf sie hast du das gefühl auch gehabt
als
das erste mal gesehen als ich muss echt
sagen ich bin ich bin das erste mal zum
casting gegangen
sie haben angerufen haben den trailer
gesehen so macht ihm so caspar
mit zum casting nach kann ich das 1 1
gesprungen und es hat so lange gemacht
und ich bin bis auf ausnahmen aus dem
studio so erklimmen
lukas ihr müsst unbedingt ich musste
unbedingt machen so ist so cool und hat
haben die das nach amerika geschickt in
amerika sagt kanz abgesegnet so und dann
er hat es irgendwie haben die mich
angenommen und dann war ich fünf tage im
studio und haben es angesprochen und hat
extrem viel spaß aber ich muss auch dazu
sagen synchron für synchron leute
synchronarbeit gut ab weil es ist
wirklich echt da muss alles auf den
punkt sein
das darf nicht gut da hab mich so lang
sein es darf nicht zu kurz sein
lasst uns toll gespielt aber einer
meiner aus vielleicht nicht ganz so gut
oder nicht es hat nicht dann von einer
längeren gehauen also davon können wir
ein meeting weil ich habe auch fünf
sekunden im film ja ein review in der
arkade der sagt zu kennen irgendwie
gehen wir noch einen zwischen dem tapas
oder so ähnlich du hast es nicht bemerkt
ich hab nicht mehr sich mehr ganz so auf
dem sturm
aber ich bin sofort zur jetzt sehr
international movie database und trat
das ein er macht es natürlich dass
dieser eine satz hat sicher fünf minuten
gebraucht
und naja also welcher dabei
es gab schon bald da ich habe sie jetzt
nicht mehr auf mich um aber da habe ich
dann auch ja wegen länge ausdruck
eigentlich wegen sprachlicher weil ich
bin ja nicht wirklich aber nie irgendwie
ich wirklich sprache sprecherziehung
also wirklich gelernt oder so und das
ist schon schwieriger wenn das erste mal
das machst du denn dann ist es einfach
achten hier auf alles sie haben nichts
anderes zu tun den ganzen tag als sich
genau das immer abzuschicken ist es
verständlich alles und so und da haben
wir schon ein bisschen judy arbeitet
okay was würdest du denn sagen ist der
unterschied zwischen der arbeit als
schauspielerin und in der synchron rolle
bei der schauspielerei erfordern vor der
kamera oder hast du interaktion also du
du kannst dich auf den anderen allein
stellen im sap oder durch spielten
miteinander beim weiler synchronarbeit
ist es so dass du wirklich auf dem platz
stehst und dann hast du hast du
praktisch den fernseher vor wir tun oder
alles abgehakt immer nur ein paar wörter
oder ein paar selbst was sie lernen
genau in einem text und alles ist so
zusammenstecken und du kannst du musst
halt immerhin ob es einer sein passt es
halt nicht wirklich gespielt sich mit
dem anderen
das spiel ist eigentlich mit dir selber
und vorbereitung drehzahl und so weiter
ist die vorbereitung in lauter danke für
eine schauspielrolle also dresden und
zeichensprache aufnahme sehr
wahrscheinlich ja aber das bloß aus
das problem ist dass die ja nichts raus
geben die geben ja keinen wechsel raus
du keins ziemlich vorher
nein das wird ich kann das nicht vor
nicht rausgeben komplett keine texte
raus du sitzt da hast den text vor die
otto und jetzt ein sprechen und dann
hast du gerade vielleicht mal so eine
minute zeit um dir den satz irgendwie
okay dann musst du irgendwie das noch
irgendwie spielen so also viel
vorbereitungszeit
na ja klar so heraus gesprochen
euro gesprochen habe man schon
dazwischen so aber es ist schon da ist
nix mit vorbereitung also ein
riesenunterschied total
wie kriegt man es dann so hin ich meine
dass hass und einfach gepasst es macht
einfach spaß und witz dabei sein das
resultat ist der hammer also es ist halt
einfach schon die erste szene wenn du
siehst du mit deiner stimme ist was hast
du in deiner kindheit hat soviel
animationsfilmen ich hab' ich bin
wahnsinnig große großer fan von
animationsfilm ja und ich hab wirklich
angefangen von den ganzen klassikern
investieren dann ruhig ihren ariel könig
der löwen und wie sie alle heißen und so
und micky maus natürlich sind auch wir
aber dann auch so die neueren sachen
sowas zum beispiel wie bolt oder so also
ich gucke das wahnsinnig gerne an weil
das hat einfach spaß macht und und half
reicht also ich also gute diesen geiler
film und scheiß also möglich
jeder kann sich das angebot eines
problem ist ja alles was mit
computerspielen zu tun und ist was für
mich war aber irgendwie spricht jeden an
so muss einmal so viel ahnung von sind
es einfach schön story für sich so ja
und dann hast du halt noch den schönen
nebeneffekt das halt wenn du so ein
bisschen ahnung von bisschen
computermesse hast dass du denn so
lustig so aber es
trotzdem alles lustig also ein traum in
erfüllung gegangen auf jeden fall auf
jeden fall auch aber soweit von ja ja
wünsche dir noch viele träume in
erfüllung gehen mit den nächsten haben
wir haben jetzt noch im kinofilm in
österreich heraus
die lebenden arbeiten ganz ganz schweres
thema komplett gar nicht wollte das
nicht so wer kommt jetzt in die kinos
und dann kommt man china fernsehfilm
dann kommt eine ganze welle blog reihe
dann arbeite ich ja quasi im hauptcast
vom blog was ich an den ganzen
interviews gemacht ja und jetzt
irgendwie sowieso alles und dahin immer
in diesen räumen kriegsrecht im ok egal
das war anna fischer bei pixum wenn ihr
sie sehen wollt wie sie schon mal da war
was auch sehr lustig war
dann klickt auf das video unter dominiks
kopf da irgendwo und wenn ihr das letzte
talk video sehen wollt mit teddy kommen
die dann hier unten klicken
vielen dank dominik dass ich bei dir
sein dürfte ja schön dass du da warst
einher